bienvenue sur cette gabare bon
chargement dites moi alors
autrefois sur ce qu'on paie comme on
appelle ce genre de gabarre c'était
plutôt de bois qui est effet le
chargement du bois pour les tonneaux des
piquets de vigne des châtaigniers c'est
le type de cargaison qu'on pouvait
trouver sur ces bateaux qui descendait
la dordogne jusqu'au 19ème siècle
beaucoup moins calme que la loire est
souvent à sec elles n'étaient navigables
que 30 jours par an d'où leur durée de
vie très limitée que marie-madeleine
vous protège et oui j'ai oublié de vous
dire que nos gabart nous courbet qui
faisaient le voyage de ce pont tour
jusque vers le bordelais ne remonter
jamais sens unique tout le monde
d'essentiellement dès l'arrivée au port
les gabarriers décharger le bateau et le
casse
et oui on déchire la gabarre
aujourd'hui évidemment ou ne détruit
plus les gabarres on les protège comme
des trésors
celle ci est la réplique exacte d'un
modèle très anciens le jury du festival
de loire lui a décerné son prix
d'honneur une prime d'encouragement pour
les gabarriers de dordogne moins
nombreux et moins organisés pour
l'instant que ceux de la loire
en 1990 il y avait plus de gabarre
quasiment et on en a reconstruit il y en
a une dizaine qui ont été reconstruites
pas identiques mais presque et ça
navigue manière touristique maintenance
sur les barrages et sur la base dordogne
dans le lot et en dordogne
donc effectivement points sans ya pas
encore ce qui existe ici de regroupement
de tous les gens qui s'occupent de
gabarre le fait qu'on soit ici avec 4
gabart différentes qui viennent de
quatre endroits différents je crois que
c'est un début et non peut-être ça va
aboutir comme les gabarres de loire
celle de dordogne était autrefois une
activité économique qu'il s'agit de
transformer à l'avenir en projet de
développement touristique
pour l'heure il s'agit avant tout d'un
folklore
à ce sujet ils ont eu aussi leur
tradition de chants de marins
et